what is that is that like a like a yoda
thing
that's fun who doesn't love emma stone
she's a brilliant actress who's played
several iconic characters over the years
but what about the ones we least
remember oh well
rest assured it was equally as thrilling
for me every actor has roles that people
forget now and again
so we decided to look at emma stone's
cinematic history as an actress
to find the characters you may have
forgotten she played
my life is not pg-13 a 2008 film
is about two high schoolers that have
one last crazy night before going their
separate ways for college
while she doesn't play the main
character emma stone plays jules
the love interest of jonah hill's
character seth her character is sweet
beautiful and she has great chemistry
with jonah hill it's also worth
mentioning that this was her first major
role in a movie
what does me being drunk have anything
to do with it the house bunny is a
comedy that was released in 2008
starring anna faris as the lead role the
film is about a playboy bunny who finds
a new home
at an unpopular sorority once she
becomes their house mother
you might have forgotten that emma stone
is in this movie playing one of the
sorority girls named natalie
natalie is a nerdy smart college student
who wants to save her sorority house by
recruiting pledges
and stone does an amazing job with the
character
no no in order to keep our house though
we do have to be popular yes
you've probably seen ghosts of
girlfriends past a movie that twists
charles dickens at christmas carol to be
about a man haunted by the girlfriends
of his past
i'm gonna take you back through all your
past girlfriend but did you know that
emma stone was in it
she plays one of the ghosts that visits
the main character connor
specifically she plays the ghost of
girlfriends past
stone's quirky but charming acting makes
us fall in love with the character
zombieland and its sequel zombieland
double tap are comedic post-apocalyptic
movies that feature emma stone as one of
the main characters
wichita she is also the love interest of
character columbus
jesse eisenberg's character wichita
cares deeply about her sister
and eventually for columbus and
tallahassee this character is a bit of a
con woman
but thanks to emma stone's acting we
can't help but root for her
she's going to become a
zombie this is one of emma stone's most
iconic roles easy a is about a high
school girl who pretends to be far more
promiscuous than she actually is
emma plays olive the main character
she's a high schooler who takes her
reputation into her own hands
when rumors start to spread about her
promiscuity emma stone's goofiness comes
through in olive
and it makes us love the character all
the more i just realized the funniest
thing
my name is an anagram for i love
friends with benefits is a fun romantic
comedy about two friends who discover
they have feelings for each other after
entering a friends of benefits agreement
while justin timberlake and mila kunis
are known for this movie
emma stone also plays a role in it she
plays kayla
the ex-girlfriend of justin timberlake's
character dylan her role
in the movie is small but her
performance is awesome
maybe you should care a little bit less
about work and a little more about the
girl that you're dating
most people know spider-man's love
interest mary jane or mj
but the amazing spider-man series
brought the character gwen stacy to the
frame as a love interest for peter
parker
her character is brought to life by none
other than emma stone
gwen is intelligent beautiful and full
of heart
making stone the perfect person to
portray her i'm sorry
no it's impressive they actually held
together very well
we laughed and cried while watching
crazy stupid love
emma stone portrays one of the main
characters hannah
stone brings silliness to the character
that no other actress would be able to
pull off
that really shows in this scene when
hannah and jacob
ryan gosling's character reenact a scene
from dirty dancing
it's funny and sweet just like stone
seriously it's like you're photoshopped
the help
pulled out our heartstrings and the
movie's success is in part because of
emma stone's acting
as she conjures character skeeter phelan
from the page to the silver screen
skeeter is a beloved character in
literature and film
while there are light-heartedness and
fun to her character the story and
message of the help
is a serious one and skeeter has a
serious depth to her that stone
executes flawlessly mama was third
runner up and miss south carolina
page the croods and its sequel the
croods and new age
are adorable films about a prehistoric
family the voice behind the character
eep
belongs to emma stone while stone hasn't
done a lot of voice acting for animation
she did an excellent job with eep
eep is a fun and energetic character and
stone brings fire to the character in
that sense
high fire while most of the films she
stars in are coming of
age lighthearted and comedic birdman is
a black comedy that has a darker tone
than what emma stone is known for
in this film stone plays sam the main
character's daughter
sam is a bit sassy and has a rocky
relationship with riggan thompson her
father
but just like all of emma stone's other
characters she's got a heart of gold
and let's face it dad you are not doing
this for the sake of art
aloha is a romantic comedy centered
around a former u.s
air force officer played by bradley
cooper but emma stone plays an essential
role in the film
her character is alison ing the air
force liaison who has an idealistic
point of view and a bright future
she's fascinated with the beauty of
space and her charming aura attracts
brian bradley cooper's character
like a lot of her other characters
alison is the main character's love
interest
i meant with you sir oh captain ring
it's ing oh
it's like ring along with her character
olive in easy a
emma stone's mia from la la land is
perhaps her most iconic role
we all loved watching the movie and
watching the chemistry between her and
ryan gosling play out on screen
her acting and how she portrayed the
character earned stone the academy award
for best actress in 2016.
two options you either follow my rules
or follow my rules
the favorite sets sarah and abigail emma
stone's character
against each other as they both try to
become the favorite of queen anne
while this movie has a darker tone to it
than most of stone's movies
there's still room for a laugh or two
since stone's character is a bit quirky
and a bit more malicious than her
typical character
which is interesting to see play out on
screen today's elder brown's day
day he lost him icarly was a hit
nickelodeon series that many of us came
to love
and still love today did you know that
emma stone guest starred in one of the
episodes
that's right she played heather a super
fan of the titular show icarly in an
episode titled i find spencer friends
it's so much fun to see stone completely
unleash her wild side as she crazily
greets the cast of icarly in this scene
oh my god oh my god it's icarly
anthony carly hi this next one
might come as a bit of a surprise even
to the biggest emma stone fans
icarly isn't the only show that emma
stone has made an appearance in
she also voiced ivana tipton london's
dog in an episode of the sweet life of
zach and cody
titled crushed this was before her big
breakout role in superbad
funny and cute why haven't we met before
darling
in an episode of malcolm in the middle
called lois strikes back
emma stone made an appearance as a
character named diane
the leader of a clique of popular girls
that seeks to humiliate rhys
one of malcolm's brothers it's hilarious
to watch lois malcolm's mom
get revenge on diane by stuffing the
heads of her dolls in her locker
diane's reaction is so funny the rocker
centers around rayne wilson's character
fish and his desire to rock again in a
band
but emma stone's performance as amelia
stone doesn't go unnoticed
she's ready to rock and ready to have
fun with her bandmates
it's also worth noting that she plays a
love interest of one of the characters
it rocks what i'm talking about instead
of a canoe paddling around on a pond we
were like a tank flying down a mountain
marmaduke isn't a classic or well known
so you might not remember that emma
stone was in it
she voices a dog named maisie a friend
and love interest of marmadukes
the character is sweet and playful and
stone does an excellent job voicing the
character
i can make you into the dog you want to
be okay cruella hasn't come out yet
but we're so excited for it and for emma
stone's performance that we have to put
it on this list
in case you haven't heard emma stone is
going to be playing cruella deville in a
movie centered around the character
it's going to be a comedic film so we'll
see if it lives up to the rest of
stone's work
what's it like to wear that black and
white hair and the makeup and the
clothes it's pretty trippy
emma stone can do it all from
light-hearted comedies to more serious
dramas
the woman can do it all let us know
which role surprised you the most down
in the comments
thanks for watching